I've sort of coined a phrase, which is,
"Get the audience at the edge
of their seat,
and while they're leaning forward hit 'em with the truth."
I didn't really know
what it was, I think,
until I was about 18 years old.
You know, I would hear it,
but I didn't really fully grasp
the magnitude of it.
What is Juneteenth?
In Galveston, Texas in 1865,
about two and a half years
after Lincoln signed
The Emancipation Proclamation in 1863,
was the time at which Black people
understood that they were also free.
Enslaved Black people.
And so, some stories go
that they had been held there
in order to keep farming the land
until the harvest season was over.
Juneteenth is a really special holiday
for African Americans.
I grew up in the South
and was aware of it at a young age.
It is the celebration of the point
at which all Black people were free.
People refer to it
as the second Independence Day.
I see it as the first Independence Day;
none of us are free until we all are.
So how did you come to do
Lincoln's Dilemma?
It was the opportunity to impact,
to add to the kind of canon of stories
about a really important
and really key president.
What you get across this county
is a history
that is often not robust and complex
around the stories of Black people.
Black people really pushed the country
towards emancipation.
There were so many actions done,
even by enslaved people,
exerting as much power as they had
in their day-to-day lives
to really push all of the country
to understand
and embrace their humanity.
I'm just curious about how this history
informs the work that you do
and, in particular, talk about Swagger.
The opening image of Swagger
is a maze. Right?
And so, I think
for many audience members,
that might just be a good visual.
But in our show,
maze becomes a metaphor for life.
But really, the maze ties back
into, like, the Harlem Renaissance,
Reconstruction, emancipation,
and wanting to feel that
in the narrative.
I've sort of coined a phrase,
which is, "Get the audience
at the edge of their seat,
then hit them with the truth."
It's important for me
to tell the stories
of Black folks in particular.
Women, folks from the South,
that's all my demographic.
It's because those stories
are not uplifted,
young Black girls, for example.
It's a charge that I gladly take on,
and, at the same time,
it just gives us so much more work to do
than the average director, right?
It's interesting to hear you say
that you think of a social cause
when you're taking on a project.
That's all I do.
-Yes.
-It doesn't matter what...
It doesn't matter if it's about
basketball, that's all I do.
The first thing that really
dropped in for me with Swagger
is that it was about 14-year-old
youth basketball players.
What I took hold on right now
is the most famous 14-year-old
in American history: Emmett Till.
There's an amazing picture of
Emmett Till by artist Lisa Whittington.
Half of the painting is Emmett looking
like the world is his, optimistic.
And the other side
is, like, marred and scarred
and really taking on
all of the atrocities of the world.
This is the side,
the positive, the optimistic,
the side that we all fight for,
for our kids, for our communities,
this is what Swagger is about.
I'm glad you mentioned that.
I think about when I was looking
at Lincoln's Dilemma
and looking at the story,
and really writing scenes
about enslaved people
in a way that I wanted to make sure
that they weren't these flat narratives.
I wanted to make sure they were infused
with all the humanity they had.
It's very interesting
that that's my charge
in 2021 when I was doing the writing.
I still need to communicate,
to other people,
the humanity of Black folks.
And so, it is still necessary,
it's a necessary charge.
Did the events of 2020 impact
any of your recent work?
It took me a moment,
but I got recommitted to my craft
and recommitted
to telling these stories.
For me, there's a gift to Black people
when I'm telling their stories
that I think I'm obligated to give.
But the work that was driving me:
I imagined that there might be
some person watching,
definitely some Black person
who sees themselves differently,
sees their history differently
by understanding, you know,
simple things like when enslaved people
were working in the fields,
they would sing songs.
You think about the songs
and you often think about songs
and entertainment
as a little bit of this, kind of, ways
that people like
to characterize Black folks
as, like, shuffling and singing
stereotype, right?
But enslaved people sang songs
in the field, work songs,
to change the tempo of their work.
They would sing slower
to slow things down.
If somebody on the end of the line,
at the end of that row,
needed to catch up or wasn't well,
they would slow them down
or speed it up.
So those were actual choices
in the ways Black people
organized with each other.
Like you, after the events in 2020,
production shut down,
just because of the pandemic.
I think during that shutdown,
initially my thought was
that when we'd come back,
we'd continue the season on as is
and just kind of stay the course.
Just hearing various opinions
that people didn't really want to deal
with the pandemic on-screen
or the events of, you know, George Floyd
-or Breonna or any of that on-screen.
-Yes.
And then it just felt like
it's a missed opportunity.
I'm an artist, I'm a Black artist,
and I have to hold a mirror up
to society right now.
I felt like one of the better decisions
I made on the show was that
we embraced the fact
that we were in a pandemic
and we embraced the fact that we
were all impacted by these murders.
It felt like it elevated
everything we were doing.
I think that there is
a kind of leveling out,
as opposed to the exceptionalism
that's often used
to refer to the way
that Black folks show up.
A leveling out and an understanding of
what we do in the spaces that we're in.
Like you said, we're filmmakers, so this
is the space in which we have power,
and it's really important
to leverage that.
And particularly
when there's backlash at times,
which has certainly been the case.
That's great, I think
one of the things that can get lost,
even sometimes when,
this conversation's about Juneteenth,
-is, like, how great it is to be Black.
-Right?
Like, how much of our culture
is a celebration,
how much of our culture
has influenced this country.
-Yeah.
-How much of, like,
Black love has sustained us.
It's sustained us, and this country.
We wouldn't be a democracy
without the work that folks did
to really push Lincoln along
to The Emancipation Proclamation.
There's not another proclamation coming.
-We have to write that proclamation now.
-Yes.
And it doesn't absolve other people
of their responsibilities.
We just have to keep moving it forward.
And we do have to stand
on the shoulders of ancestors,
and we have to be the shoulders
that other people can stand on.